liberal San Francisco trying to lure
tourists back and reboot itself as a
quirky and fun place to be by spending
Millions on its first ever ad campaign
welcome to the most beautiful city in
the world where it's never the same but
always San Francisco
[Music]
wow that place looks fun too bad it's
not real this pricey ad conveniently
forgets to mention that half the
sidewalks are covered in feces but
there's also almost 40 000 homeless
people doing drugs and camping out too
and also a guy riding his bike filming
row after row of abandoned shops in the
ones booming downtown area
things aren't better in nearby Oakland
where residents vented their frustration
over high crime
I just want to turn to the audience
and ask them who here has been assaulted
well that was pretty powerful that town
hall is that going to change anything or
no because they these are the same
people that vote for these people so I'm
glad that San Francisco is is trying to
get out of their problems using PR they
need to spin the negative into a
positive for example think about the
exercise you get running from muggers
and rapists the added adrenaline of fear
can't be matched on a Peloton plus with
all the feces on the street it's a hell
of a plyometric workout and as an
optimist I prefer to see the streets
that's half empty with feces and if
you're a fan of the city and you're also
a fan of the outdoors you're always
faced with a choice what do you do on
the weekend we love the city but you
have to drive to the country not in San
Francisco you can live inside and then
Camp outside on your street and you get
all the Thrills of the Wilderness with
wild naked hairy bears but it's kind of
sad I have to say it's sad that they
have to play the rainbow card you know
please come to San Francisco because
we're so pro-game okay sorry guys you
can get that anywhere now right it's
even Chick-fil-A says we're gay so it's
like saying we have running water the
real sad part about this is they can't
sell the big things because they can't
solve the big problems they can't say we
have Law and Order we can't say we have
Safe Streets or poop-free escalators so
all they're stuck with is is is this
it's kind of sad they're literally
painting a turd well someone got paid
whoever did the ad took the money and
then they'll probably get it again next
year it was six million dollars to do
the ad and last week Michael
schellenberger told us that he that the
city of San Francisco is in a deficit of
500 police officers so you imagine six
million dollars could have been spent on
one retention bonuses to try to get
police officers to stay or signing
bonuses to try to hire new police
officers I understand the desire to try
to get people to come there I imagine
that the hotel industry is very upset
and perhaps the theaters and the venues
are upset because nobody's going not
only like flying there do something but
let's say you live 30 minutes out
there's no reason to go to the theater
and go to the shops around the theater
because the shops have closed and the
restaurants have closed so it's not safe
to even be there so why would you drive
in you would just stay home and watch
you know
Jesse Waters prime time is San Francisco
past the point of no return I hope not I
think all great cities have the
possibility of a Revival and I hope that
it does by mid-july when I'm going to
visit and you know we should send you
with a camera crew so you can you know
Brad already suggested that and I said
hard no hard no hard note a man lady on
the streeting around
um would it be a team player Jessica
sorry
um I just couldn't do it as well as you
did back in the day so good
um but I've been struck I was looking at
hotels the prices are so low compared to
what they used to be you can stay in the
nicest hotels in San Francisco where it
used to be over a thousand dollars to
stay in a Four Seasons or a Ritz Carlton
it's about 500 you could say at the W I
think it was like 325 a night I'm not
saying that that's no money but it's a
lot less money than it used to be this
is somewhere that people really wanted
to go on a vacation I noticed in the
Airbnb scene a lot more places popping
up outside the city if you want to stay
in Sausalito or in Mill Valley just 15
minutes to get into town versus places
in the city yeah obviously I can't
expense this trip see that's easy that's
what she's doing she's using she's
talking about it
you are one smart Satanist nobody knows
even how to expense anything it's too
complicated
Johnny could do it for me but I
I'm not trying to make Fox pay for this
trip but I think that it does what
you're seeing set up is this new
frontier of how elections are going to
be fought which is between Democrats
more moderate Democrats that acknowledge
what's going on in the the line between
the policies that have ended up with
these results and the Democrats who
continue to talk about it as if these
things aren't going on because crime and
homelessness are one and two of the
issues that just make sense to people
where you can see it and it makes a
difference if you look at the race in
Colorado Springs for mayor for instance
the guy who ended up winning that was so
much more conservative on crime and
policing than majority of Democrats that
are running you look at mayor Adams here
in New York City he beat out more
Progressive Challengers by talking about
the fact that he was a cop that he cares
about getting more cops on the street
that we can't continue to be this way
and so you know when you talk about will
this make a difference Republicans
aren't going to win these elections but
more conservative Democrats certainly
could Jessica makes a great point I
can't believe I just said that but
all we want is for some Democrats to
acknowledge there's a problem
some Democrats haven't even acknowledged
there's a problem in San Francisco why
not uh wouldn't you love to get on a
time machine and go back to the summer
of 2020 and have Democrats smart
Democrats like Jessica and play the tape
from today to people who are protesting
for the defund the police movement it's
like and a lot of the frustrated
citizens in Oakland are saying this is
what you get this is your Progressive
dystopia this is what you sold us these
are your policies and to your question
are we past the point of no return we
don't know yet because we're still very
much in the middle of it and we're still
electing these Progressive Mayors and
DA's in the case of California it's not
going to be until you elect someone
who's more conservative and they cannot
get control of the city that's when you
know it has gone too far and no one
wants to get to that point Vander Beek
he has to run for everything Greg yes
everything only that giant head of James
Van Derby can save us
all right and James Vander Beek and
Jessica will be signing autographs at
the W or the Four Seasons in San
Francisco
tomorrow Prime Time aren't you an
exclusive yeah for the whole hour the
entire it's a town hall with vanderbee
yes they'll be taking your questions
from the farm I want to Brian Kilmeade I
want you to do me a favor I want you to
click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is
this way that I
that commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now